le pays du vent des ciel lumineux ou
bien violets et gris le pays du sel des
sables trempé qui ne finissent
caen-la-mer tiède c'est là entre cheikh
ul mont saint michel le plus vaste
terrain maritime de france huit fois par
an au marais de plus de san lameer
couvre tout seul vie les moutons 2500
sur mille hectares des rebuts et 19
berger dans cette étendue
quand ils disent je monte au mouton cela
veut dit je vais les chercher vers la
mer depuis les bergers d'arcadie un des
plus vieux métiers du monde un métier
d'homme simple mais qui comme personnes
sont en contact avec la vie animale la
vie de la mère les eaux le soleil se
rappelle jane russell g vers les moutons
environs du peintre d'avant je
conduisais détracteurs depuis la guerre
je suis tombé comme affirmé je ne
pouvais pas marcher beaucoup alors je
pouvais plus me être actuel parce que
quand fallait servir les gens me
débrouiller je n'avais plus la force
dans les jambes alors le patron ini tu
peux les garder les moutons et je me
suis mis à dos les moutons et ça fait
quand même vingt ans les gardes les
moutons moi tous les jours comme ça je
viens aux prés salés
je montre mes moutons euros j'ai raison
ventana la cabane de mon copain pour
passer mon temps j'allume du feu je me
mets à lire les bouquins
[Applaudissements]
montazeri
ça fait 13 ans que je gère mon mouton
j'ai même eu moutons chambre remontant
au jeu de scène montre pour ma part je
fais mon travail je peux faire c'est
michel sculptures et après je fais des
bouteilles mont saint michel en
bouteille se passe mon temps au soir le
billet je me rends aux mots tel un
mouton qui tu vois je vois la lgv à la
mer puisque cette fois je trouve bien
des choses nous revient avec et pillent
j'ai mené à tabac non mais en tant pis
vont chavez a appris avec le facteur
mais mon copain
traiter les 16es rien à faire je vous
envoie les voies d'une fois par jour si
on a le temps comme on dit
comme il fait très chaud on aime mieux
rester à l'homme dans nos cabanes google
veut voir nos grands choix délicat est
mis dans son bien il fait très chaud
d'aller se promener en mobilier à
tourner la loi mais voir les copains
plus loin à aller plus loin et on
continue notre chemin tour comme ça d'un
côté à l'autre
c'est le seul travail des bergers
c'est l'hiver que ces produits l'hiver
ici c'est mon autour de la personne ne
voit personne personne c'est monotone
mais bon on ne peut pas les voir
beaucoup les copains parce qu'elle est
allée même les moutons est bas mais on
est entre amis jamais parce que l'on se
promène par les prés salés
on va voir la mer promettent
je m'ennuie pas trop pensé quand
j'arrive à ma cabane jeu je fais la
sculpture je fais des tableaux
je fais le mont saint michel en
sculpture je fais bien des choses
le mont saint michel en bouteille pour
passer le temps je peux pas rester sans
rien faire faut que je travaille
c'est plus fort que moi au joueur que je
travaille à bien la paire fille de
montjeu les vents ils menaient pas mal
demander
j'en ai à peu près au moins 40
bouteilles qui aura fait de bouteilles
en haut du tableau j'en ai encore plus à
faire mais c'est la planche il manque
surtout le bois ils monnaient demandé
beaucoup de bois
quand on dessine bien sûr ou bien quand
on sculpte quand on travaille le bois
pour aider un peu les journées à s'en
aller
on prend ce que l'on a sous les yeux ici
il n'ya que le mans et les moutons mais
le monde n'est jamais pareil
quant à la cabane elle est pauvre mais
pas bien close une silhouette insolite
biscornu qui est posée là sur la netteté
des sables pour le berger c'est un
pseudo mer on peut se fixer son adorée
c'est aujourd'hui oui des jeunes
ta voix là georges kiejman or l'accès du
chien doit elle aurait passé la glotte
m
sont invités dont tu viens voir je viens
du haut à wind mobile embourbé bateleur
de bolbec oui bah c'est ce que tu avais
travail à faire
[Musique]
elle vous était en hausse et restent
amis prés salés comme tout le monde je
lui avais dit à leo voir hidalgo de loi
qui ça s'est produite le salaire il
alloue un jeune mouton comme auprès de
suites remakes du lait de la mère non il
n'a pas le goût spécial dans la nuit aux
blancs et vous prenez moi septembre et
la d1 chromage ces quatre toques
mauvaise année là prenez en de la jouer
près de mort soit prés salés et lors de
nos précédents et que vous le savez vous
ne savez pas quel morceau vincennes où
vous vous trouvez
[Musique]
boutin ils marchent debout avec pas le
mouton
ça va pas vite mais ça va je vous y
allez devoir le mouton à l'alcool
pour la chine il s'agit du rapport à les
moutons sauf que tout va du centre est
en tout cas se demander si ça va tomber
du passé il faut y aller avant que ça
tombe alors là il faut que ça reviendra
faire mais comment tourne à la mi-temps
sur dans les clichés sont les rois quoi
ressemblent-ils ou pillées hubei part
avec la mère elle est légère symbole loi
dit on va parler se marier quand même
pour la mi temps on est beaucoup mieux
mais ce que ça valait la laine d'acier
et tout ça ça va je crois que c'est le
fumier la part de plus les filles entre
d'estrun donateurs question d'heures
gérard a pas beaucoup voir
c'est quoi travaillent à leur travail il
faut être là quand même
c'est un travail qu'il faut tout oublier
et un retour au bercail dur bébé lente
il retrouve les faibles tout le choix
j'ai lui va venir troisième
[Musique]